لن تبقى له حصون ولا مدن ولكن لا يعتقد
كثيرون هنا في شمال شرق سوريا ان تنظيم
داعش زاله يقولون انه باق في مخيمات
والسجون وخلى نائمه ورحله البحث عنه لا
تبدا الا من مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
الدخول لمخيم رهول السدعه التنقل في مركبه
مصفحه وحراسه مسلحين من قوات حمايه المخيم
وهؤلاء لا ينتشرون عاده داخل المخيم بل
يكتفون بمراقبه البوابات وتسير دوريات لكن
جوله كهذه تثير مخاوفهم من هجوم مسلح او
حتى بحجاره
[موسيقى]
ثلاثه
وخمسين دوله يقطنون هنا ويتوزعون على سته
اقسام غالبيتهم من عائله الدواعش قدمنا من
الباغوز ومناطق اخرى بدانا جولتنا من قسم
مهاجرات هو الاسم الذي يطلق على قسم زوجات
الدواعش غير السوريه او العراقيات
واطفالهن به خيام وسوق للملابس والخضر
من اين انت
الكستان تتحدثين قليلا من العربيه لن يكون
الحديث مع الكثير منهن يسيرا رفضت بعضهن
الحديث
واخريات اعاقهن اللغه
متى اتيت الى هذا المخيم
الاقتراب من اخريات كان اسهل لكن الحديث
معهن كان ينعطف سريعا الى السماته في
الدفاع عن التنظيم
[موسيقى]
يعني هذا اوامر من خليفه اجاعدنا
املازم اجباريه
في خذنا مع امريكيه مع اخوان جاهلين ها
انتم تطلعوا هناك ان شاء الله
طبقتم شرع الله
[موسيقى]
لا ترغب ام محمد وهكذا تسمي نفسها بالعوده
الى مصر فهي تعتقد انها تسميها دوره
الخلافه ستعود ترغبين بالعوده الى مصر
ركنه اخريات ربما يئسنا ويامن فقط بان
يعدنا لبلدانه الله
ترغبين فعلا بالعوده للمغرب فعلا اكيد
اليوم قبل بكره
ندمتي على ذهابك
يعني لازم نحن نرجع بلدنا ما يضلوا اودعنا
هيك يعني في
المخيم يعني انت شوفي يعني معروف الخيام
والوسخ وكل شيء يعني لازم يعني
ترحيله عائلتي داعش وتفكيك المخيم مسعا
عبرت عنه قوه السوريه الديمقراطيه التي
طالبت مرارا دولا باستلام رعاياها من
عائله التنظيم برايي الشخص انه اكثر من
خمس سنين او ست سنين احنا بحاجه لالهم
لحتى نفكك مخيم الهول بالكامل لانه العدد
كثير كبير العدد ضخم انت عم تحكي عن 53
الف لاجئ ونازح عندك العراقيين ما يقارب
27 الف عراقي والسوريين اللي موجودين هني
نسبتهم اكثر من 18 الف سوري اغلبيتهم هنن
من مناطق سيطره الحكومه السوريه
وعندك قسم خاص بالاجانب اللي هنن
المهاجرات او اذا بدك تخلي المخيم منهم
هنن بحق بحاجه لقرارات دوليه صارمه حتى
انت تقدري تفكي المخيم وترجعي كلها هدول
لبلدانهم
مهمه صعبه اذا فيما اداره المخيم وتامينه
يبدوان اصعب
[موسيقى]
كان في حمله امنيه للقوات حمايه المخيم
داخل المخيم خلال الحمد لله الامنيه تنضب
كميه كبيره من الاسلحه كمان تم القبض على
كثير من خلايا داعش
خطر بدا اوضحه بعد اكتشاف شبكه خنادق
وانفاق محفوره تحت الارض لتهريب السلاح
ومتطرفين واموال صار بن عيشوبه العربيه
مخيم الهول في شمال شرق سوريا